genou à terre des dizaines de migrants
d'amérique centrale implore joe biden de
les laisser entrer aux états unis des
scènes qui se répète jour après jour à
la frontière américaine qui fait face à
un afflux sans précédent
selon le ministre de la sécurité
américaine près de cent mille migrants
en situation irrégulière ont été arrêtés
à la frontière sud des états unis en
février 30 % de plus qu'à la même
période l'an dernier
le pays attend un flux de migrants
historique à sa frontière
nous sommes partis pour voir arriver
plus de personnes à la frontière sud
ouest que nous n'en avons eu au cours
des 20 dernières années
la situation est difficile nous
travaillons 24 heures sur 24 pour la
gérer dès son arrivée à la maison
blanche le président américain signé un
moratoire sur l'expulsion des migrants
arrivés dans le pays avant novembre 2020
mettant également fin à la politique de
séparation des familles durant sa
campagne
joe biden promettait un nouveau statut
pour la totalité des 11 millions
d'immigrés qui vivent en situation
irrégulière dans le pays
pour les républicains la situation aux
frontières résultera de l'abandon de la
politique migratoire de donald trump la
sécurité de notre nation et de notre
frontière est d'abord et avant tout la
responsabilité d'un autre président je
suis venu ici parce que j'ai entendu
parler de la crise
c'est plus qu'une crise c'est un drame
humain ce qui est triste dans tout ça
c'est que ça aurait pu ne pas arriver
cette crise a été créée par la politique
présidentielle de cette nouvelle
administration
elle ne peut avoir d'autre nom que la
crise bail de nos frontières
pour l'heure la majorité des familles
sont renvoyés vers le mexique où leur
pays d'origine en vertu des règles mises
en place pour lutter contre la
propagation du coronavirus mais le pays
doit faire face à une arrivée croissante
deux mineurs non accompagnés qui eux
sont prises en charge par les états unis
des structures d'accueil dédié aux moins
de 18 ans depuis bien longtemps saturé
selon la ministre de la santé américaine
en février près de 10% des migrants en
situation irrégulière arrêtés à la
frontière étaient des mineurs isolés